so Mario asks is it possible to divide
leptons and quarks into more fundamental
quarks and how can we prove that they
are the most fundamental particles if we
can't keep doing this can we only
separate one particle into smaller
particles well that's a good question
because the history of physics is that
we have found that if we look at
elementary particles atoms we discover
that they're made out of simpler objects
I mean democrates over two and a half
millennium ago hypothesized that all of
matter was made out of atoms which and
atoms were always thought to be
indivisible point like objects and in
fact we discovered convinced by the end
of the 19th century that matter indeed
was made out of atoms but understood
very soon that Adams had structure
electrons and nuclei and then we
understood that the nucleon has the
nucleus of atoms has structure the
nucleus is made out of protons and
neutrons and later we've understood that
protons and neutrons have structure
they're made out of point like quarks so
today our standard theory of elementary
particle physics is based on a theory of
matter which identifies the basic
constituents of matter as point like
electrons neutrinos and quarks but of
course everyone was open to the idea
that electrons and quarks themselves
would exhibit structure and might be
made out of even more fundamental sub
electron sub quarks we haven't given
them good names because we haven't found
them we've been looking
we now can probe the structure of
electrons and quarks down to let see
roughly one millionth of their size so
it's as if we have a microscope where we
can blow up a quark to a very big radius
and look inside with great detail and we
have seen no evidence that they have any
structure at all now it just might be
that the point-like objects were looking
at inside quarks and leptons are even
smaller but there's no evidence for that
at all and it could be that this is the
end of the story
could be that quarks and leptons are
themselves truly the point-like
constituents of matter however there are
various open problems in elementary
particle physics and our exploration of
matter that suggests that there is no
physics at shorter land scales but it
might be of a different nature and
indeed there are attempts to unify all
the forces of nature based on something
called string theory in which when you
look at a cork with a very good
microscope much much better by factors
of a million times a million times
better than what we have today you would
see not sub quarks not that the cork was
made out of three or four or some number
of smaller units but rather the cork is
not a point-like object at all it's an
extended streamlined object it's a
vibrating string and that's a totally
different approach to what makes up the
different elementary particles not even
smaller point-like particles but
different modes of vibration of a single
extended object and string theory in
fact you have only one string but it
vibrates differently
different kinds of vibrations much like
a a violin string has many different
harmonics and in string theory all the
elementary particles that we see our
simply different vibrational modes are
the same extended string so that's a way
of having sub structure but not point nu
point like sub structure